[Musique]
que révèle le fleuve saint-laurent
de sa naissance à la sortie du lac
ontario jusqu'à son estuaire dans la
région québec ces eaux sont sous la
loupe groupe de chercheurs
c'est la journée la plus chargée à bord
du navire lampe silice le laboratoire
flottant s'arrêtera sur dix points
d'échantillonnage on récoltera avec
cette bouteille les zones les plus
contaminées du saint laurent non
regardez visuel
cela est oublié auquel elle est encore
quelques mains
les dernières missions du lam silice ont
révélé la présence d'importantes
concentrations de coliformes fécaux sur
la rive nord du fleuve allant de
montréal au lac saint pierre l'équipe du
professeur françois guillemette retrace
l'origine des colonies de colis souvent
responsable de la fermeture des plages
cette bactérie vie dans les intestins
des humains et des animaux à sang chaud
je commence et elle reste des techniques
moléculaires les poulies la génétique
des fameuses bacri
et de voir avec qui elle est ce qu'on
peut dire bien sûr mais maintenant cette
bactérie là a une âme et un port une
vache par exemple ball un oiseau ces
résultats préliminaires sont surprenants
le rôle des municipalités dans la
contamination bactériologique du fleuve
pourrait être plus important qu'anticipé
on va faire comme beaucoup de gens par
exemple serait tributaire
amener des charges importantes sauf
plutôt agricole par exemple viennent ou
forcés de quelques tributaire de la
région de retrouver certaines sources
proviennent mais dans le fleuve en tant
que jeune pour l'instant c'est
principalement une source humaine
l'une des principales sources de colis
les rejets d'eaux usées de la ville de
montréal
c'est ici entre varennes et l'île aux
vaches que les conduites déverse
bactéries ces résidus pharmaceutiques
on est environ un million d'accord que
les français comparent 100 ml d'eau du
tri qui donne les moyens aux standards
et donc cour d'appel la baignade est
d'environ 1 200 et 1000 pour les
activités de contacter un prix
avantageux
on est vraiment content id dans mon sang
dans les astres comme ça très grosse
entrée
pour les prochaines semaines
perché à l'avant du navire matthew
chapman scrutin archipel dans les
environs de varennes je dirais c'est
surtout à cause du fait que je suis
rêverait de
ce sale rat dans un souci de partage des
connaissances scientifiques
l'équipage l'a invité à bord du lynn
silice le militant écologiste s'est
porté acquéreur de lille à la truite
2020 une île en plein coeur de
l'effluent de montréal j'aimerais bien
me baigner pour mai en france mais n'y
est pas possible à l'heure actuelle à
cause de la pollution dans l'eau la
ville de montréal n'est pas la seule
responsable des concentrations
importantes de coliformes fécaux en aval
d'autres rivières sous pression
contamine le fleuve on a déjà une charge
importante l'offre qui te des petites
municipalités en plus les distributeurs
qui vont plus au nord l'accès est bien
avant de rajouter ça va se poursuivre à
nhk 3 revient comme ça le rsa savoir
c'est qui qui avait le plus ou moins
deux spots question est pour l'instant
votre clavier qui a
avoir des formes sont en rien à voir
avec montréal d'importants efforts
devront être consentis pour rejeter des
eaux plus propres montréal elle planche
sur une unité de désinfection dont la
mise en service est prévue pour 2025
j'aimerais les usines de traitement de
l'eau sont à la hauteur du défi c'est de
traiter l'eau comme fo avant de le
déverser dans les cours d'eau autour de
nous simplement ce qu'on doit par
exemple mettre des usines de traitement
des eaux usées à jour dont c'est un gros
enjeu les surverses aussi où se détendre
au d'importantes qui la capacité de
traiter des brûlures mais pas assez
suffisant durant les épisodes de ford
maintenant puis est-ce qu'on doit
maintenant penser à dire cela de
l'argent doit aller pour maîtriser
les usines à jour
les observations sur m6 lice dévoile
l'ampleur du chantier qui attend les
municipalités ici jacob côté radio
canada trois rivières
[Musique]